NHS the National Health Service turned
75 today but there are serious concerns
about its long-term health
the health secretary denies conservative
Cuts have added to NHS woes and insists
it must remain free for everyone
a service to Mark the anniversary but
amid the celebrations how do we ensure
the NHS remains fit for purpose
[Music]
thank you
good evening and welcome to a special
program on Sky News as the NHS turns 75
it is under unprecedented pressure
record waiting lists increasing demand
from an aging population squeezed
budgets and doctors and nurses quitting
the service in droves it all means that
almost every part of the Health Service
is under huge strain so what's the
diagnosis what is going wrong what is
the cure how do you turn the service
around is it just a question of money or
do we need radical reform in the way the
NHS is structured and funded to help us
through all this and to give us quite
differing opinions of the way forward we
have in the studio Lord Winston
professor of Science and society and
Emeritus professor of Fertility Studies
at Imperial College London and Dame
Claire Gerardo president of the Royal
College of GPS and co-chair of the NHS
assembly will also be joined a little
later by Leading hell health
professionals Frontline doctors who will
give us their diagnosis and possible
cures for the NHS
but first what is the state of the NHS
at 75
here's Tom Cheshire
there's all sorts of data here but let's
start with some of the basics this shows
the number of beds per thousand people
and you can see how it's come down over
the last 20 years to just about to it's
nearly halved in fact now that decline
is a trend worldwide this hospitals
don't need to keep patients in bed for
as long and here's France and Germany so
similar size economies they've had that
decline but they still have many more
beds than the UK does today they have
more beds in the UK did two decades ago
or take doctors ever since the
foundation of the NHS the UK has had a
pretty low number traditionally this is
all the way back in 1960 it has been
adding over the decades especially you
can see this growth over recent years
you can see where we are now it is a
long way behind behind Germany catching
up to France so there is progress there
the other thing when we talk about
pressure is vacancies today there are
around 110 vacancies across the NHS
despite efforts that number has been
more or less the same since it was five
years ago now last week we had the NHS
long-term Workforce plan which one they
could reach as high as 360
000 if no action was taken or the plan
was all about how to avoid that still
there are big questions of the
implementation over hiring new employees
but especially over retaining existing
staff now add all of that together and
this is what you get on the patient side
this is the length of waiting list
compared to the same month in 2019 you
can see here if we're going back to the
days of the pandemic there is a dip
we've picked here Sweden and Ireland
because they keep the same sort of data
similar detail there's that dip and then
it goes back after that but what happens
with Ireland they managed to get out of
that pretty quick Sweden Rises a little
bit now seems to be living out a
different story in the NHS in England it
is way way up here and as we heard today
likely to rise further and then lastly
the really big picture how much of our
GDP has been spent on health you can see
it here since 1970 again taking and
increasing share people living longer
conditions becoming more complicated
costing more money basically as we ask
the NHS to do more we often hear about
record levels of funding but again
here's Germany and France for a long
time the UK has been behind that and
they have different funding systems
they're still spending significantly
more and that remains the case today the
UK wants their sort of Health outcomes
and that's a debate too the money needs
to come from somewhere
Tom thanks very much indeed so that's
the big picture well the health
secretary Steve Barkley has told Sky
News that the government is determined
to ensure uh that the NHS remains free
when people use it
but we're committed to that and I think
there's real opportunities and we put
out announcements this week on for
example Artificial Intelligence on early
screening of lung cancer didn't the NHS
will need to evolve much more onto
prevention rather than simply looking at
treatment as we have the pressure of a
growing older population also people
living with multiple conditions one in
four other British public now have two
or more conditions and that's why we're
focused through our major condition
strategy at looking at treating people
more holistically
now to Mark the 75th anniversary of the
NHS the health Think Tank the king's
fund has been assessing the state of the
NHS and has done also a comparison with
Healthcare Services in other countries
so what did they find well joining me
now is the director of communications
for the Kings fund Andrew McCracken
thank you very much for being with us
and you and other think tanks have a
very sobering message for the government
on the NHS uh years of under investment
you say and shameful neglect of social
care
yeah we've issued a warning today we've
written to the leaders of the three main
political parties in England
um to raise the alarm really about
political short-termism you look at the
NHS as it turns 75 today and frankly it
seemed better days public satisfaction
with the NHS is at its lowest ever
record but interestingly public support
for the founding principles of the NHS
funded through tax free at the point of
use universally available are absolutely
Rock Solid and what that tells us is
that the public don't want a whole new
model of healthcare they just want this
model of healthcare to work so our call
on the party leaders today is that the
next general election needs to be a
decisive break point away from
short-term policies about quick fixes to
thinking long term about the Health and
Care needs of the nation that's things
like investment in buildings and
Equipment finally reforming adult social
care and also thinking about the things
that are outside of Health and Care that
affect our health things like transport
things about access to Green Space what
the government could be doing to help us
lead healthier lifestyle so rather than
us getting sick we stay healthier for
longer right now we saw I'm talking
about comparisons you did this report
very recently I think last week on
Health Care Systems in other comparable
countries what did you find
yeah you're absolutely right we did so
we looked at 19 countries including the
UK countries which we felt were
comparable to the UK and Nations that
we'd like to compare ourselves to we did
find some positives so perhaps
unsurprisingly given the model of
healthcare that we have people are very
well protected from the costs of care so
there's very few people in this country
who avoid health care because of the
cost we also found that it's quite an
efficient system so in the UK we only
spend about 1.9 percent of the spend on
Administration whereas in countries like
France that's 5.5 percent and in the US
it's as high as nine percent but we also
found a lot of negatives so when it
comes to the human resources in the
Health and Care System we're below
average on both doctors and nurses and
when it comes to the physical resources
we were for example Rock Bottom when it
came to the number of CT and MRI
scanners per thousand people and then
perhaps the one that should be most
alarming is where we fur when it comes
to life expectancy the sort of ultimate
measure of the health of a nation and of
those 19 countries we looked at we came
second bottom only to the US so there's
clearly room for improve and that's why
we've been calling on the political
parties to do the long-term thinking
rather than just lurching from crisis to
crisis right and just finally to be
clear is there a system of Health Care a
way of funding health care that leads to
better outcomes in your view
I'm really glad you asked this because
we've seen in recent days people talking
for a total overhaul of Healthcare in
the UK from our study of these 19
countries and previous studies there is
no one model of funding Healthcare that
is inherently better than another What
It ultimately comes down to is to be
blunt and to really simplify it you get
out what you put in so whether that's a
social health insurance model or a
private healthcare model somewhere along
the line people have to pay and it needs
adequate investment to make sure that
you get the right level of Health
outcomes that you as a nation want
Andrew thank you very much indeed thank
you so let's examine then in a bit more
detail the current state of the NHS with
Lord Robert Winston professor of
Fertility Studies at Imperial College
London Dame Claire girarda also here
president of the Royal College of GPS
and co-chair of the NHS simply thank you
both for coming in Claire first of all
your assessment of the NHS at 75. yes
and there's so many complex issues
aren't there first of all I'd like to
say thank you to those 1.2 million
people who today have been serving and
the people of this country and to hear
something that that seems very negative
must be even more demoralizing for them
but it is complex I mean over the last
10 to 15 years we've seen uh we've seen
social determinants of Health get worse
you've picked up green spaces but we
also know homelessness poor housing and
all those things poor nutrition so it's
not and the NHS is picking up those
issues we've also seen our economy go
down so if you think about the the
amount of funding from GDP of your GDP
goes down then your funding available so
it's very complex if you're saying to me
does the is the NHS today should it
change yes of course it should change we
what you haven't mentioned there is that
we need to be delivering much more care
in Primary Care in general practices in
the community rather than I suspect and
I worked in the NHS for 40 years are
sort of fixation with hospitals we have
this sort of National Hospital service
we talk about protecting a e rather than
how can we ensure that we make general
practice fit for purpose and actually
keep people out of hospital and and
allow them to receive the treatment they
need in the community yeah and we're
going to talk about the problems as you
see them diagnosis and then we'll go on
to talk about the cures during the
program
um but just very briefly do you think
the NHS is sustainable in its current
form the NHS needs to shift there needs
to be three major shifts which I'm sure
would pick up prevention which you've
talked about personalized care in other
words giving patients much more control
of their own illnesses their own life
and also shifting resource to primary
care so three major shifts if it doesn't
make those major shifts then I do fear
for the future of the NHS Lord Winston
your view of the current state of the
NHS I'm not as optimistic I'm afraid
because I think first of all actually we
had some very interesting things just
there just to Sidetrack and then patch
you'll ask me the question again but one
thing while I'm in mind we've got the
largest employer perhaps in the world
almost one of the biggest of five
employers and the amount of money spent
on Administration is absolutely
insignificant and actually the the need
to administer that far more effectively
is really clear it doesn't matter
whether it's in the Health Service or in
general practice or certainly in Social
care but I think that's one thing that
we need to just keep in mind because
well no doubt come to that back of that
in answer to your other question I think
I mean to prefer taking it back in in
reverse order first of all of course
we've handed more to general practice
and and Primary Care since landsly and
actually that actually hasn't really
helped the hook so the whole service
that much and certainly patients own uh
possession of their care is certainly a
good idea but so far nhsx which has now
been on quite a long time been around
for quite a long time hasn't made a
fundamental difference and what was the
first thing the first thing of course
which of course is clear is absolutely
right not really one of the big problems
is essentially in just simple terms one
word National Poverty and poverty is a
massive problem in Britain and we are a
poor country because we've not run our
managing we don't manage our finances
unless she rightly says of course that
results in all sorts of things in
education in the environment and so on
without going into those details that
has nothing to do with Healthcare it
actually Healthcare has to try and
prevent protect that and ultimately
what we heard also just now was very
important is that in fact there's a
decrease in longevity in Britain which
is really striking I was on a select
committee which looked at that and the
and the facts we saw were pretty
horrifying actually and completely
against the the promises of the
government the reverses actually
happened you make pledges but actually
if you don't do something about it and
that it needs a completely different
kind of political structure to deal with
that which we're not going to get this
way because ultimately we're not being
honest about health care right and just
very briefly in this section Rishi sunac
talking about this Workforce plan labor
talking about preventative medicine and
so forth I mean have they got it right
at all I don't think so because first of
all if you put you know all the doctors
in medical school that you really need
and actually it's a large large number
you're going to have to wait 10 years
before they're qualified and they're
going to be a general practitioner at
least another three or four years to get
them really up and running through a
consultant a bit longer consultant red
service 15 years is too long to the
weight and so I don't think in in
minutes and we're losing people all the
time don't forget we're losing them from
general practice as well as from
hospital care because of disenchantment
and that's happening in nursing
colossally we're not bringing people
back there retiring very early and
that's that's an issue which the
government has referred completely to
its angle right Claire I saw you shaking
your head there and you're going to get
a chance when we come back because we're
going to talk about the problems as you
see at the diagnosis as you see it uh
you're watching a special edition of the
NewsHour at Six coming up a diagnosis
for the NHS we'll hear from two
practitioners on the front line an a e
consultant and a doctor specializing in
palliative care and we'll have more from
our guests here
[Music]
foreign
and now they're going to be arrested we
aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
yeah
the roads have been inundated the only
way out is to get people by boat
what is here that over 200 people might
have died because of these landslides
[Music]
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted
this is one of the most sensitive areas
of of Northeast Delhi where there's been
clashes
I'm Neville Lazarus and I'm Skye's
reporter based in Delhi
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to this special edition of
the NewsHour at six where we are
debating can we mend the NHS we want to
spend some time now diagnosing the
problems facing the health service at
the moment Lord Robert Winston is here
and also Claire Gerardo and we were
having a discussion about the the state
of the Health Service now the problems
as you see it Claire you were shaking
your head when Lord Winston was speaking
from a gp's perspective what is wrong
quite simply they're not enough of us we
haven't got enough time to spend with
our patients and or our communities so
just to give you that sort of I've
worked as a GP now for 40 years in the
same practice when I started the average
consultation rate I.E how many patients
at the number of times a patient
attended per year was about 3.2 it's now
7.7 so every patient on average attends
more than seven times a year now some
people out there were saying well I've
never come no because the highest
attending patients come 22 times per
year and what I do now is has no
resemblance to what I did when I first
started as a GP in terms of complexity
in terms of the patients that I'm having
to deal with in terms of just the
decisions that I'm going to make yet in
the last 10 years we've had Flat Line
number of GPS in the community so as
your piece has shown unless we redress
that unless we really do create more GPS
and start to allow me to use the skills
that I I've got amazing skills then I'm
afraid that the NHS will fall over if we
go on uh putting more money into into
Hospital Services more staff into
hospitals then we're just going to get
increased costs and actually patients
are going to we've got a e departments
saying actually look we're under you
know so much stress and it's partly
because you know GPS are not taking the
workload office now well I can I argue
the point though why why is it GPS
taking the workload off why is it a e
taking a workload off GPS today about
1.3 million people will have seen had
contact with their general practitioner
that's an awful lot of people we are
unless people have been in sort of Cloud
Cuckoo learn we are inundated with work
in general practice my surgeries will go
from 7am to 7pm my colleagues have no
breaks so it's not about relieving the
pressure in the hospital system it's
about working together to make sure that
patients receive the care that they need
timely care in the place that is best
for them and the place that's best for
them is the community not in hospitals
where actually that they're really
places that if you're very sick you
shouldn't be Lord Winston
I'm very uncomfortable indeed about this
apparent
argument between
Primary Care Service and service in
hospital I don't think it's productive
of course clear is Right we've woefully
underfunded general practice I have no
doubt about that and I can see that
visibly I have so many friends who are
general practitioners who are finding
ways of trying to get out of being
general practitioners and seeing others
who've retired and huge
dissatisfaction and in fact trying to
make an appointment for one's GP unless
your GP is very very assiduous it's very
difficult I'm very lucky I've got a good
GP but actually overall there is a
colossal problem there and that is
completely right and absolutely correct
but ultimately one of the problems with
medicine now is that it is very much
more much more complicated when either
clear or Iowa medical students it's
completely changed it's now very high
very high quality High expensive
investigation for quite simple things
and if you get those wrong then actually
there's a problem and getting those
extra into in math now just
just getting those into general practice
is really difficult I'd do quite regular
lectures to GPS for example on
Reproductive Medicine and it's really
interesting you know reproductive
problems are really common I mean we're
talking about vast numbers of people in
Britain who actually offer childless so
it's one of the commonest problems
General Practitioners don't have a clue
about how to really do that they feel
completely powerless because they've not
been able or trained to do it and it's
one of the problems so it comes to a
consultant-led practice but actually the
relationship the relationship is wrong
so we end up with people going through
in vitro fertilization who've never had
the diagnosis made so they're having the
wrong treatment I I well I'm we're going
to get into fertility I mean it's a very
good model I know you're absolutely
right one in five uh individuals have a
fertility problem probably one intern
actually but okay so we can argue I've
had the details but it's not because we
don't have the skills to identify it
it's very unusual now for services to
fund at IVF but I don't think that's
part of the problem that we're sort of
discussing here I think the and I
absolutely agree I think to get into
this dichotomy primary secondary it's
one system of health care if one part of
the healthcare is is overwhelmed then it
ripples through to the rest of the
healthcare system so we now need to be
working together as one system we need
to be working breaking down those walls
those artificial barriers between
primary and between hospitals and the GP
surgery it's one system with teams
coming in and out of of hospitals into
Primary Care okay uh now I'm joined by
uh Dr Rachel Clark who is an NHS
palliative care doctor and author and Dr
Ian higginson he's an emergency medicine
consultant and vice president at the
Royal College of emergency medicine uh
welcome to you both and I um I hope
you've been listening to what's being
been said
um Ian will come to you in a moment
Rachel
first of all we're talking about the
diagnosis of the problems here give us a
sense of what it's like for you at the
moment dealing with your patients many
of whom I assume are end of life your
treatment
yes absolutely Mark that's right so I uh
work in a very busy Urban NHS hospital
and as a palliative care doctor I go
across every Ward a e intensive care
every bit of the hospital and what I can
say without a Shadow of Doubt is in the
15 years I've been a doctor it has never
even remotely been as bad as it is now
there are unimaginably horrible
degrading and horrendous things
happening every single day in NHS
hospitals right now and uh in end of
life the one thing you desperately want
for your patients is for them not to
suffer and for them to have at least a
shred of dignity well that can't happen
if you're having to have end-of-life
conversations literally in a corridor in
a e in the back of an ambulance because
the hospital is so full we can't even
get our patients out of the ambulances
into hospital and this isn't a winter
crisis occurrence it's something that
now is literally happening almost day in
day out so this week my hospital is on
black alert that's something that used
to happen only in the dark depths of
winter it's early July and we don't have
any beds in the hospital so what I'm
seeing is the human face of what I
consider to be a 13-year problem in the
making of a degrading down of NHS
capacity NHS Staffing to such an extent
that now despite our every best efforts
and you know I like so many people will
stay until seven eight o'clock at night
when I'm meant to go home at five we all
do that because we care about patients
but our best isn't good enough We are
failing patients and it's not a general
practice versus Hospital issue it's
across the board every single
sorry to interrupt Rachel but is this a
problem of Fallout from covid or is this
nothing to do with covid now it's this
is something that has been building so I
I started practicing in 2009 and
although things weren't perfect it just
was not the case that you treated
patients in corridors like this but it's
slowly been building and even before
covert the the winter before covert
began when we first saw patients in in
March 2020 that winter again the the
conditions were dickensian in a e you
know patients sitting on chairs lying on
the floor sometimes they were working so
much so this is a a capacity problem
that predates covid covid has certainly
made it worse but we already had over
four million people on waiting lists
before covert it's it's something that
has happened over the course of the last
decade or so okay now we're going to
come back to you for your suggestions
about what could happen
um Ian Dr higginson and I suppose there
should be a full disclosure here my
wife's in any uh consultant she says you
know a e departments are under
considerable strain give us a sense of
the picture as you see it
uh thank you um so considerable strain
is probably a polite way of putting it
for for many of my colleagues but um
let's just take a step back
um what's right with the NHS is that the
NHS is stuff full of really amazing
Healthcare professionals uh whether
they're doctors nurses whatever their
specialty and many other professions to
beat uh what's what's been going wrong
is that the the lack of long-term
strategic proper planning proper
investment in that Workforce proper
investment in Social care proper
investment in the facilities means that
those brilliant people can't do their
jobs properly and that's at the heart of
this
um so when you extrapolate that to
what's happening in in emergency
departments around the country we see
the effects of that the emergency
departments are an excellent barometer
of what is going on because
um we are if you like the ultimate
safety net for for many of the failures
elsewhere in system as well as being the
the place you would choose to go when
you're acutely ill or injured and our
hospitals are full our emergency
departments are full which means that we
are having to treat patients in
corridors or in ambulances and our staff
are run ragged trying to deal with that
and this isn't because they are not good
at their job it's because they don't
have the resources and Facilities to do
their job properly so that's that's the
fundamental problem affecting the NHS
and that is the result of long-term
failures
um sadly in in the health policy at its
heart and I mean we're going to come on
in the next section to what you think
you know might happen but are you saying
that it's not sustainable unless there
is some sort of change in in you know
and in the way it's funded or the way
it's structured
uh there's lots of ways of answering
that I mean the old adage that if you
keep doing the same thing time and time
again and expect different results is
really true and we've been doing an
awful lot of that whilst we've been
chucking in short-term money
um when things have come to a crisis
point in an attempt to beat the
headlines and to to provide us with a
little bit of a buffer
um so it it clearly isn't sustainable as
things are at the moment I don't think
anyone working certainly in the Urgent
and Emergency Care sector uh would would
suggest that
um so whether that means you know
simply simply providing staff with the
capability to do their job or whether it
means different other reforms is another
question the sort of changes we tend to
see tend to be a bit short-term tend to
be rearranging organization chairs that
sort of thing they don't really uh
enable staff to do their job better on
the whole right so Ian hold that thought
because we're going to talk after the
break about what needs to happen now so
uh we'll be back with you Ian and Rachel
and also back here in the studio you're
watching a special edition of the
NewsHour at Six coming up the debate
continues all our guests what's the cure
for the NHS should a payment or
Insurance model be considered
[Music]
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to this special program
devoted today entirely to the NHS on its
75th Anniversary we've discussed what's
wrong with the health service now we're
going to look at possible solutions
including whether patients should be
asked to pay
um Lord Robert Winston this is an
important part of all this you want to
see radical reform in how we Finance the
NHS well this is quite extraordinary you
know I'm being accused of wanting to see
patients pay more I haven't said that at
all I haven't remotely said that so I
mean I'm being accused of something
about financing which I haven't
considered I'll tell you what I want to
see yeah I want to see for the first
time some honesty which would mean
actually knowing what each treatment
actually costs you know we don't know
what treatments cost they cost for
example sometimes five times the amount
in Leicester compared let's say with
Birmingham and that doesn't make any
kind of sense it's never been a property
costed treatment and in any part of the
service are we seeing a rising to
trajectory of what we're paying and a
rising cost of how much Med Center is
probably costing but we don't know the
difference so we need to if you've got
to run an industry you've got to work
out that basis that means actually
really doing something very fundamental
which actually means using proper data
control to actually see what you're
spending on how you're spending it and
we don't do that until we do do that we
have a massive problem secondly I think
there are all sorts of ways we could
bring money into the whole service which
we haven't even remotely considered in
this program and well I'll give you one
let's consider it now something I
suggested to Tony Blair in 2003 I
remember it was exactly when it was it
was in January when he was there was a
crisis and what he did instead he put
very well he put a huge sum of money
into the whole service and he papered
the crack for quite a long time and for
several years that made a big difference
one of the things one of the typical
things I said to him was look you know
if you take the model that I've been
running at Hamilton Hospital what you do
is you take the private patients your
your your your
using whether they're from overseas or
Britain and you put that money into
public care and actually you make this
sure that they set they share the
services they share the premises and
instead of having Outsourcing into the
into a private thing which is vastly
overpriced you actually start to find
how you supplement Healthcare and
actually you reduce the cost of care
right across the board by doing that and
that model actually worked brutally at
Hammersmith It produced a huge sum of
money for the NHS we didn't take private
fees I was accused of doing private
practice but I've never done Private
Practice yeah actually what we did in
fact was to make certain that we were
presenting a really good service without
charge for something which was not
serviced by the NHS would you rule out
some sort of insurance no I wouldn't the
thing is I wouldn't rule out anything
what I would want to see is something
that we're not doing which is actually
to have an honest discussion between
political parties at the moment the
Health Service is a political for
football so at one moment we're saying
one thing with one group and you know
basically Kirsten who's a really good
man saying one thing prime minister
saying something is different what we
need to do is to sit down and work out
really what we're doing and actually
have an agreement about for example how
much we're spending of the gross
national product on Healthcare and then
seeing what the deficit is and then
seeing how we fund that deficit some
sort of hybrid system it would be
possibly well certainly because in fact
what we see very very good example in
fact the kingsman's shown this there are
a number of countries in Europe for
example which have a system which really
works very well without a huge impost on
the patients but with substantially
Better Health Care right across the
board including Primary Care as you see
in Israel for example as well as
actually so these this is people paying
a proportion of their earnings well it
may be or it may be an insurance I mean
I think I think I think it's it's just
let me just finish one thing I think the
point is this you don't put anything out
of mind at this stage so actually say
look let's really rethink what we're
doing and see where we're going not
making any promises social insurance
systems will cost a phenomenal amount to
run you'll have to have systems within
in within all Healthcare organizations
so can we park that I'm actually feeling
a little bit uncomfortable about the
nihilistic the nihilism that's coming in
about the National Health Service and
the language that it's broken that it
needs fixing every single day we're
delivering excellent care every single
day
hundreds and thousands of people are
getting access to investigations to
treatment for cancer every single day
babies are getting immunized women are
giving birth and we're treating people
in primary care and doing them so I
think we've got to be absolutely clear I
don't think anybody the services
you've got two doctors here we just and
I cannot deny that they were saying
things are pretty bad and I cannot deny
that their experience and I actually
think as we've said earlier there are
all sorts of other things that are in
that are happening at the moment one is
of course that we don't fund social care
so we're sending old people sadly into
hospital it's appalling that Rachel's
having to deliver palliative care in
accidents and allergies it's absolutely
appalling but you could say that's
because further Downstream we don't have
enough hospice care we don't have enough
Community palliative care systems we
don't have enough of people like me who
can do home care who can help people die
at home so I'm not denying the
experience but I'm actually saying it's
bigger than the NHS and if we continue
to downplay the achieve achievements
today I was in the QE2 with the
Parliamentary awards from hundreds of
people delivering fabulous characters
across anybody's downplaying the
achievements I just wonder I can't what
I'm trying to work out is what the
system would be that you want if it's
not going to be if it's not going to be
a different way of financing what is the
what is it changes there are no perfect
systems so the social insurance system
which is for example Germany you you
have it partly paid by an employer and
partly paid by the employee but it has
to be propped up by the government in
other words they have a hybrid model of
a National Health Service a
government-funded state-funded and
employee employee funded for that to
work you have to have good relationships
with your trade unions and your
government and your employers I'm not
sure that would work in this country
there are the National help the national
health because and the other thing if I
can finish the other thing is to have
why not
why wouldn't the social why because I I
think you just need to look at how many
strikes when we've got at the moment in
our natural our natural the the trade
Union's relationship with government so
it just wouldn't work you also have to
have a means of taking the money
literally at the moment the the
government gets our money for the Health
Service through taxation so there's a
hmrc
quite simply I don't know the mechanics
but basically gives over a certain
percentage of our tax money if you're
going to be having somebody with their
credit card as in France tapping a
tapping a system we've got to have a
whole different form of and we've seen I
think you said five percent or six
percent of administrative costs in
France and and in Germany here two
percent I think the figure was those I
mean because those admin costs would
rapidly rise people paying to go and see
a GP what would you think about that
well I mean it's a silly idea isn't it
it's like saying well who will pay that
will be the tax on the middle the middle
squeeze the squeeze middle because you'd
have to have exemptions and they'll be
the same exemptions as you have for
prescription charges so about 80 of
people are exempt from prescription
charges so you'll have you your your my
sons his friends who will be paying so
it will be the squeezed middle we also
saw in in in Ireland how it didn't work
how they had to rapidly reverse it
because actually it stops people
attending who should attend so we've got
to you're looking exasperated
not a good system a good system and
funded through National taxation we have
some co-payments prescriptions what
Winston Lord Winston was talking about
which is the Hammersmith I suspect was
the infertility Services which of course
is how infertility services are funded
because they are so appallingly funded
by the National Health Service so it's
it's the reason he had to do it and
bless him he did it is because of a
deficit in the NHS it certainly wouldn't
help if we did that for all services
very very quick very quick because
before we bring the because actually
let's just say that actually Private
Practice in London has changed for
example London but it's true across the
country has changed completely in the
last 20 years now a lot of people are
going into private medicine that weren't
before so there actually is a pool of
money there that could be differently
spent for example as any one example
there are many other things we could do
yeah okay let's go back to uh Dr Rachel
Clark uh the NHS palliative uh doctor
also Dr Ian higginson a e doctor was
speaking to them earlier about the
problems as they saw it so
um Rachel uh what so come on then what's
what should change what needs to change
what should happen
well I think Lord Winston is absolutely
right that we should be considering apps
everything all possible measures but I I
think it's really important not to
assume that because conditions are so
bad currently within the NHS that means
the system is broken we have to have a
new model of funding there's an awful
lot of rhetoric around that at the
moment but we have to remember that over
most of the last 13 years the NHS has
been subjected to the longest and most
Draconian funding squeeze that is as
ever faced in all its 75 years since
1948 so uh Jeremy Hunt was the longest
serving Health secretary and for most of
his tenure the NHS budget only Rose by
about one percent whereas Rachel just
very quickly so if I can interrupt just
very quickly isn't that one of the
problems with a holy taxpayer funded
that you're going to be in some ways at
the whim of economic you know crises
every now and then isn't that one of the
issues
I think I I think it it boils down to
whether or not you have a government
that is willing is willing to have an
open and honest and Frank conversation
with the public you know that the public
nobody's stupid we all know that we get
the Health Service we are willing to pay
for and if we want a world-class Health
Service that is tax funded we need to
pay for it I think one of the problems
we face at the moment and this would be
the first thing I'd love to change is a
system where politicians
constantly make up fantasy unicorn
stories about 40 new hospitals that
don't exist or a Workforce plan that was
was announced last week with great fan
flat fair and flourish but a plan that
actually had not one single idea about
how to retain the precious NHS staff we
have who are hemorrhaging in their
droves and that's the second most
important thing for me we need to be
doing everything we can to retain the
staff we have because they are the
lifeblood of the NHS without the staff
there is no NHS so okay addressing
things like pay is absolutely essential
even if it's politically unpalatable for
Richie sunac all right Rachel um thank
you very much indeed so Dr higginson um
what do you think we should be looking
at what what should we be doing
um thank you well I'm a relatively
Simple Man and I I would I I I I think
uh to start with we we just need to get
the basics right
um so if we accept that the NHS is stuff
full of amazing people who um are doing
a fantastic job and could do an even
more fantastic job uh given the
resources to do it why don't we build on
that so let's stop treating the NHS like
a political Football let's uh get
consistent long-term well thought out
plans that we
um keep going despite the political
climate think it through let's invest in
community-based Services which would
include primary care and many other
services invest in Social care so that
we're not concentrating on hospitals
where we don't need to and then with
regard to to the rest of it let's put in
those beds that we need the information
systems that we need and crucially
crucially we need to recruit and more
importantly bring attain the staff and
then when you start talking about reform
if you put our staff in an environment
where they've got the Headroom where
they're not run off their feet and where
they can think properly and work
properly they will innovate they will
find the savings they will do the things
that will continue to make our health
service
available to our patients Lord Winston
is a a a classic example of that look at
what he has achieved over his career
given the Headroom to do it and given
the support to do it and the NHS is full
of people who are capable of doing that
right so staff is the Bedrock of the NHS
it needs proper planning proper
investment that's well thought through
and doesn't change every time the
political wins change okay Ian Rachel uh
thank you both very much indeed for
contributing this evening appreciate it
thank you
thank you so uh throughout the hour
we've been debating the future of the
NHS it's not long enough really is it
now but let's speak to someone about
their experience of being treated by the
NHS Michael Rosen is a former children's
Laureate he also spent 48 days in
intensive care with covid-19 at the
start of the pandemic pandemic and he
joins me now uh Michael thank you for
coming on just tell us first I gather
you're a fan of the NHS tell us first
about your experience in hospital
uh yes I was uh diagnosed with covid
taken into intensive care as you said
then given a 50 50 chance of waking up
from the induced coma I was then uh kept
in an induced coma for 40 days
um and then had to recover from that
because I was deconditioned as the
doctors and nurses pointed out meant uh
I couldn't stand up so I then went to a
rehab hospital where they taught me how
to walk basically I went in and they
said we'll teach you how to walk in
three weeks I didn't believe them but
they did so in all I was in hospital I
was one of the covid Pioneers if you
like
um March April May and June it just ties
over
um 2020. well it's good to see you
looking so well what about this issue
that we're talking about I mean do you
think the NHS goes on as it is in the
way it's financed or do you think there
should be a you know a willingness to
look at another way of financing it what
is your view
uh well I'm somebody who's in favor of
state finance that's my own political
view and economic view I think it can be
I think possibly it has to be in smaller
units the way in which it works but
you've heard from people who have been
working in the NHS for years and years
so I will always listen to them
um I don't see that the model is wrong I
mean perhaps some of the ways in which
it's managed might be that might be done
better and I very much like hearing the
idea that you have faith in the people
there the innovators and the experts who
know what they're doing and why they're
doing it and they need the support and
that as well the point that was being
made that if you treat it as a football
that you can play around with it between
different governments there has to be
some way in which you can secure it for
longer than the political term
um and play around with it like that it
has to be seen as an agreed National
Asset that is there by the way in which
for the purpose of us loving each other
that's what they nhses it's a caring
institution and it enables us to love
each other through taxation if that
sounds you know slightly exaggerated I
mean it to be so yeah okay well listen
as I say it's good to see you looking so
well thank you very much for coming on
the program and uh this hour has flown
just before we go uh let's get some
final thoughts we've got three or four
minutes I'm told uh Professor Winston
and Dame Claire Gerard uh Claire first
of all yeah I mean it's been a very uh
interesting hour I think the for me
that started off by saying we need to
shift the funding we need to have much
more around prevention so that we're
living we need to narrow that gap of the
19 years that we're living with ill
health we need to put much more into
personalization patients having power
over their own their own health having
choice and we need to put much more into
primary and Community Care and what we
haven't mentioned the real driver for
that is digital and data we're on the
brink of a digital Revolution we've got
precious little funding in order to to
implement the digital Revolution so I
think if we're going to do anything over
the next year two years it's actually to
to seize the budget put it into
prevention put it into into digital and
then I think we're going to have we're
going to be able to lift our heads up
this this and actually start to innovate
and do the things that we know we need
to do and is there a public role in all
this in terms of Lifestyle there is a
public role the government role in that
yeah I mean I'm co-chair of the NHS
assembly which includes people from the
patients care and those who run big
patient organizations they've come up
with a patient compact so it's not just
the doctors and nurses what we will
deliver to you which is what's in the
NHS Constitution but what we expect from
them from what you expect from them in
terms of addressing their own health in
terms of taking medication all sorts of
things so of course it's public but
fundamentally I mean the government
issues around we're getting fatter I
don't think that's an NHS issue I think
that's a much bigger public health issue
that needs to be addressed okay
um three minutes
um you've got well I mean you've got the
last one I mean it's a long last word
I think actually you know what one of
the problems I mean very briefly I don't
know that's great but it just purely as
a scientist if you look at the fact that
you have preventative medicine what you
just do is delay you delay death you get
older better but you still end up with
the same diseases that they'll use
they're gonna have to treat them so
actually you don't save money in the
long
so basically I think one of the issues
is that we need to actually look at
those statistics much more carefully
that's what I'm saying because I think
we don't analyze exactly that issue and
I think that's one of the big problems
but wherever we look we're not really
taking
care to really try to look at what we
could know that we don't know and I
thought I thought our colleagues that
you've had on today were really quite
mind bending and you know it's really
shocking to hear that because of course
what we're doing you know we're praising
the Health Service and we're celebrating
the 75th anniversary and doing so the
Chelsea Westminster Hospital for example
which is about the best funded trust
probably in London if not in the in the
country in a very very rich part of
London that doesn't really reflect true
Health Care anywhere and actually
fundamentally we're because we don't
want to depress people and because we
don't want to be shroud waving we do
actually risk not really getting the
government down to real issues before an
election this becomes very important and
actually we've got to get our
politicians really to think and not make
the sort of kind of announcements
they're making at the moment and I think
that's one of the problems for both
parties at the present time I'm not
convinced with Russia's xenox fans and I
think we need to talk much more
carefully together what about and his
idea of a raw commission and getting
together and politicians you know to
tell you the truth is I don't know why
we need a raw commission I mean there's
very clever people you have four of the
the big think tanks coming we discussed
that actually in 1997 uh before the 11th
party got into power and there was a
real issue that we did think about and
then we rejected the idea but actually
maybe that shouldn't be necessary all
God it depends what you want to get out
of that and what you think you can get
out of it 20 seconds okay I think we
need to reduce the number of years we're
living with ill health fundamentally
okay so that means prevention that means
getting fitter means stopping smoking
and it means addressing those long-term
conditions that we have all right look
we could go on for another hour but we
haven't got it but thank you both very
much thank you so that is our special
program tonight on an NHS that means so
much to all of us but which we also see
well struggive battling uh for life we
will all need the NHS at some stage of
course we heard from Michael Rosen there
with his tribute really to the staff of
the NHS and the way he was treated so
it's important to ask the questions
about what sort of NHS will serve Us
best uh the problem clearly is that
there are no easy answers as we've found
out this evening but uh for now from all
of us here a very good evening to you
foreign